well every year channel 8 partners with
local charities for our founders day as
we give back to the community
and this year we're working with three
square food bank in the salvation army
yeah this is coming up this week and for
some people here in the valley access to
fresh water
it is still a challenge and that is why
the salvation army is holding a water
drive
we have bianca holman live now with how
you can help good morning bianca
hey good morning john good morning alex
so when it comes to those summer months
we're always talking about it stay
hydrated you hear sherry every morning
she says grab a bottle of water and stay
hydrated for some folks
it's not that easy and so we're here
with the salvation army
juan helena salinas excuse me so tell us
you are out there in the streets every
day
you know what is it like for folks who
can't have access to fresh water
well you know i think for us it's we
take it for granted right we can grab
grab a bottle of water from our fridge
for somebody that's out on the street
it's not as easy
on our campus we have about a close to
five acre campus where we dearly
mostly with people that are temporarily
experiencing homelessness
not only that we have homeless veterans
we also have a community meal we serve
four meals a day on our campus
but one meal is strictly free to any
that anybody that is homeless
and one hour we can serve anywhere
between 250 to 800 meals
and that is excellent for sure and so
tell us about the drive that's happening
right now the water drive that you're
doing
so the water drive in conjunction with
ford border company and the kawabanga
bay goes from january 11 to january
january june i'm going backwards june
11th through june the 20th
and you bring a case of water and then
you get a discount coupon to come to
kawabango bay
for sure so you come get to cool off in
these the lazy river or
slide down the slides but uh shane huge
with cow bunga bay tell us
how important is this for you all to
partner and kind of give an incentive
for those providing water you know it's
really good this year because we're
getting back to normal last
season we couldn't do a lot because of
gathering and everything so this is
really our first big kickoff for a
charitable event
we always love to partner with other
businesses and we can use a facility to
offer
sort of perks for people to come so if
you bring in the water you get a great
great discount to kawabanga bay
all right wonderful so again while you
drink your case water picking up those
things from the supermarket
again pick up another case for somebody
else and again we're going to have those
details on how they're trying to fill up
f-150 with cases of water to help again
keep our community hydrated back to you
guys in the studio